salud en directo américa de france en 24
ya está conmigo en el estudio más
romeros a la mar si yo le digo que el
mundo todavía sigue en pandemia eco beat
19 cómo están las cosas que diría usted
buenos días raúl pues la verdad lo que
dirías que es una decisión relativamente
previsible de organización mundial de la
salud seguir en pandemia yo sé que todos
a veces nos hemos relajado un poco
gobiernos y personas pero eso no quita
que la realidad de la pandemia sea la
que sea estás vamos a repensar
precisamente las cifras como para ver en
qué en que andamos no hay un reporte
semanal que hace la organización mundial
de la salud que coincidió con este
anuncio que hicieron de que seguimos en
pandemia de kobe 19 y si repasamos las
cifras de sus boletines semanales que
nos dicen cómo la situación
epidemiológica del mundo entre el 4 y el
10 de abril
vemos que seguimos con 7 millones de
contagios que se reportaron en esta
semana y 22 mil muertes en todo el mundo
eso significa aunque son cifras altas
significa un descenso del 18 y de 24 por
ciento respectivamente
y esto calculado respecto a la semana
anterior
una de las mejores noticias de hecho de
este boletín es semanal que anunciaban
ayer es que si revisamos las muertes
recogidas por la organización mundial de
la salud kobe 19 desde el inicio de la
declaración de la pandemia vemos que
estamos en el punto más bajo este
gráfico muestra desde el marzo de 2020
al inicio hasta ayer hasta en el final
del gráfico entonces vemos que estamos
en uno de los momentos con una
mortalidad más baja por la pandemia y
eso es claramente es un motivo para
alegrarnos yo le preguntaba es el
principio mar porque si estamos en este
punto de muertes tan bajas porque el ao
ms sigue sigue afectando sobre la
emergencia sanitaria en la que vivimos
yo sé que es importante pero por qué lo
hizo pues claro hablamos de 22 mil
muertes que puede parecer muy poco
teniendo en cuenta las cifras que
anunciando desde hace dos años pero es
una cifra muy significativa también en
el nivel de contagios no 7 millones de
contagios es mucho y es uno de los
motivos por la realización de la
organización mundial de la salud para
decir que seguimos en pandemia además
también porque hay varios países que
pueden haber relajado el sistema de
conteo entonces eso hace que esos
contagios podrán estar reportados por lo
más acertado y sea exacto un subregistro
además es importante decir que a
términos de números matemáticos no hay
una definición clara de lo que es la
pandemia no hay un umbral de muertes un
umbral de contagios que debamos cruzar
para decir que ya no estamos en pandemia
que hemos pasado a una parte endémica
sino que se considera pandemia cuando la
emergencia sanitaria lo que requiere es
una respuesta coordinada internacional
tiene frente a una crisis de salud
pública algo que sigue siendo real en
este momento además también por lo
imprevisible del virus no una endemia
cuando hablamos de endemia son ciclos
previsibles de enfermedad que no puede
prepararse el commit 19 desgraciadamente
sigue siendo imprevisible lo vimos con
un micrón entonces pues a pesar de que
todos estemos muy cansados y que no hace
falta que sigamos viviendo como en 2020
no significa que no haya riesgo y de
hecho mike bryan director ejecutivo del
programa de emergencias del cáncer
mundial de la salud compartía unas
palabras en ese sentido
queremos dejar atrás del trauma de estos
dos últimos años todos se han visto
afectados por ello pero como en la vida
no se puede hay que abordar los
problemas que llevaron a este trauma hay
que abordar las debilidades que nos
llevaron a donde estábamos si se quiere
evitar eso en el futuro el futuro es
bueno nosotros en este bloque si dejamos
a un lado la pandemia para hablar de
otra noticia de una nueva explicación
vuelve a alertar sobre el virus del cica
sea mi miedo de que no me quiero
imaginar cómo se haga el sica porque es
mucho peor cierto mal pues depende de
hecho ahora vamos a ver cuáles son
síntomas pero podría ser que te viera y
ni siquiera te enterarás valer esta
investigación está publicada en la
revista self reports y básicamente es un
grupo de científicos que trabajaron
sobre cómo se transmitía el virus y qué
podía pasar con las mutaciones no
encontraron una mutación que podía
traspasar las barreras de inmunidad
previa y hacer que fuera más contagioso
estos descubrimientos todavía son
teóricos en el laboratorio no ha
sucedido en la vida real pero pues nos
llaman a no olvidar este virus que
recordemos que se transmite por unos
mosquitos y que como te comentaba el 80%
de las personas infectadas podrían no
presentar síntomas o síntomas pero que
mujeres embarazadas puede provocar daños
congénitos en los fetos y que pues que
nazcan por ejemplo con casos de
microcefalia entonces pues es algo que
debemos seguir vigilando ahora
desapareció y la tensión mediática
significa que va a desaparecer de la
vida real pues no no esa crisis que hubo
entre 2016-2017 de sica en brasil y en
sus países de américa latina fue muy
alta revisemos brevemente las cifras
vemos que los casos semanales llegaron a
superar los 35 mil sin embargo a finales
de 2017 bajaron a aproximadamente 1
centenar unos centenares a la semana esa
baja transmisión se ha mantenido pero
eso no significa que haya desaparecido y
por eso es que es tan importante estar
pendientes de eso y más sabiendo ahora
pues que este virus puede mutar muy
fácilmente y puede provocar una nueva de
crisis de salud pública eso que nos
llama pues a dedicarle más de
investigación a no olvidarnos de que lo
que sucedió en 2017 y lo que podría
suceder en el futuro y sobre todo el
llamado a investigar una vacuna no
parece que si no estamos los medios
encima de estas enfermedades no importan
o no son tan importantes y es muy es muy
clave recordar que debemos prevenirnos
también contra esta enfermedad así es
más muchísimas muchísimas gracias como
siempre por toda la información de salud
nos vemos mañana con más pasamos